hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast standing up to the
quality of our data with research
Quality Assurance presented by dr.
Rebecca Davies associate professor at
the Department of veterinary population
medicine at University of Minnesota I'm
Suzy Valdez of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
excited to give you this educational
webinar presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars before we begin I like to
remind you that this presentation is
interactive we want to hear from you so
questions and comments could be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen once there
is many questions as we have time for at
the end of this presentation also if you
are viewing a presentation in this slide
window to enlarge that window click on
the lower right hand corner icon of the
slide window if you cannot hear or see
this presentation properly let us know
by clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button and let us
know that you're having the problem and
now no further ado I'd like to turn over
the presentation to dr. Rebecca Davies
welcome talking with you about research
quality assurance and hopefully plant a
few seeds about new approaches that we
can take to stand up for the quality of
our data as Suzy mentioned I'm from the
University of Minnesota and the director
of a program called quality central
where we're working hard to try to
integrate quality assurance best
practices into our service training and
research programs and we're interested
in doing this because it's research
scientists what we care about are our
data and truly no matter what kind of
data we collect whether it's in the
biomedical field or any other field of
study our data are what are most
precious to us and what we need to
protect safeguard and secure for the
life cycle
it's development and certainly for the
lifecycle of our research so it doesn't
really matter whether the data we're
collecting you work at the bench level
or whether you work with population data
whether you're interested in generating
policy whether these data of our data
are quantitative or qualitative what's
very important to us as scientists is
whether these data are protected with a
data stewardship approach and I really
believe that the in the current climate
for science that we really need to
participate and I would argue that we
need to lead in addressing some of the
concerns associated with research
reproducibility and by doing so by being
engaged it will allow us to stand up for
the quality of our work and work to
develop sustainable risk-based
strategies for ensuring reliable and
secure data so today my remarks are
going to be very briefly to discuss some
of the threats to research and data
quality and then move into strategies we
could perhaps consider for addressing
threats and strategies that are being
considered and being implemented by our
stakeholders both people who are most
interested in the data that we generate
as part of our research projects so my
remarks again will focus almost
completely on whether research Quality
Assurance could be one of hopefully
several scientist driven strategies that
we can use to demonstrate and improve
data and research quality so basically
when we think about research data
quality I think you would all agree that
there are at least two aspects one are
the sound scientific principles be the
heart and soul of our science the the
thinking that you folks you researchers
put in when you design a research
project based on a strong research
premise
those types of principles would be would
include things like sound study design
approach to research bias the
statistical models that we select and
use to evaluate our data and our ability
to make appropriate and accurate
inferences in response to our data and
then the second aspect would be good
quality practices so in other words
we're thinking about what we do what we
decide to do and how we make those
decisions and also how we do it what are
our practical approaches to generating
those research data to answer our
critical research questions so when we
think about our research in that way and
we want to consider what are the threats
to sound science to our ability to
generate quality research data and make
accurate research inferences I think
many of us are familiar with thinking
about research fraud down in the tip of
this triangle and of course research
fraud is something that concerns us all
but data have shown that it is a very
small contributor to sort of the
questions about our research data two to
three percent and I'm sure that's a
number we all wish would be smaller but
I think that it we need to think broader
in terms of data integrity and research
integrity and many people are now
spending a lot of time thinking about
what are being called questionable
research practices these are areas of of
our research conduct that perhaps we
could do better and many of us would
agree that things like study design
appropriately addressing bias our
statistical methods our areas that can
that can contribute to research
variability and that certainly might
affect the ability of our research to be
reproduced so those are questionable
research practices that might be a
target for improvement but then there
are also other behaviors associated with
how we do the work we do is simple
carelessness errors that that
always occur in that we need to learn
from our routine behaviors our habits
and the critical influence of mentoring
so as you consider those threats that I
recently are just mentioned a second ago
these threats are not described or
included in the role of the incentive
system which is when we talk about
research reproducibility many times as
scientists we bring up or we consider
the role of the incentive system as
being a contributor to our problems with
research integrity and my remarks are
not going to focus on this role I am
more interested in looking at how we can
secure the data we collect and in our
individual and group environments so I'd
like to use this slide just to summarize
what I've been saying for the last few
moments this is a table from the World
Health Organization guidelines quality
practices and biomedical research that
was provided in around 2006 and it's
freely available online and I like this
table a lot because I think it
summarizes how silent scientific
principles and good quality practices
contribute to the credibility of our
results and I'll let you look at that
for yourself and I'm sure this this is
very intuitive and non-controversial but
something we perhaps don't think about
enough that no matter how good our
science is our premise our hypothesis
our study design if we don't have good
quality practices we're likely to suffer
from that in terms of the credibility of
our results and just as importantly no
matter how good our research conduct
practice is if we are conducting very
good practices in the in the use of
research designs that are not good
science the good quality practices won't
save the credibility of our research
results
so as we think about the necessity of
having these two aspects of our research
be strong and calling attention to this
recent paper by Leonard Friedman and
colleagues reproducibility 2020 progress
and priorities it was just made
available online through PLoS and it
really does a nice job of summarizing
what some of the issues with data
reproducibility or research
reproducibility are and as I looked at
that paper and and reviewed the work
that's been done so far so far the
answer to this question is have we got
this covered
are we strong now and do we have
strategies for addressing research
reproducibility my answer really is that
possibly we still have more work to do
and as we think about that work I just
want to call attention to the influence
of our stakeholders who I think have
made a fairly robust and rigorous
response to the concept and the
weaknesses of perhaps our research
progress and so the stakeholders to our
research data our research inference and
our publications are of course the
publishing agencies they have a lot at
stake for publishing the data that we
generate and submit to them the funding
agencies of course who are funding our
work but other groups are also
interested in research outcomes and that
would of course be the government
agencies professional organizations
private research organizations and no
doubt the public has a very strong state
based on public support of research and
their high hopes for the research
outcomes that that we all seek to
deliver and as we think of those
stakeholders these data come from
another paper from Friedman who was an
economist and he looked at the cost of
Eire reproducible research so what he's
conducting is research on research how
are we as researchers
doing an our goal to provide solid
biomedical research outcomes and in this
charge he reports based on on his team's
economic analysis that half of the u.s.
annual investment in research is deemed
to be here reproducible based on their
analysis and what and that analysis was
based on reviewing these pivotal
research projects and trying to see if
they could be reproduced based on what
was provided in the manuscripts and he
provides in this table the categories
that the problems were able to be
generalized to and so the categories of
preclinical ear reproducibility in this
research were proposed to be problems
with biological reagents and reference
materials so 36 percent of the research
studies that they evaluated they were
not able to get enough information to be
able to do another study and use them
and find and use those critical reagents
study design was problematic and nearly
a third of the projects data analysis
and reporting about an equal number and
then the absence of effective laboratory
protocols to allow work to be reproduced
and when you look at those four
categories you will see that this these
data really guided the response of our
stakeholders and what you see on this
slide is some indication of what the
publishers and our National Institutes
of Health as a funding agency where
their response to research ear
reproducibility has been focused so in
both of these the the publishers and the
National Institute of Health have
focused on what can we do now to help
scientists improve those categories so
study design methods protocols and when
you look at the NIH response
some of you may certainly be familiar
with these already this response has
been in the last year and they have
requested that that the application
instructions from scientists for public
funding need to be improved and focused
directly on enhancing rigor and
reproducibility and when you look at
their four strategies that they're
asking for additional details into the
scientific premise the hypothesis the
soundness of the approach they're
looking for more details and a expanded
description of that experimental design
they'd like more details about relevant
biological variables again the soundness
of the science and then the
authentication of key biological and
chemical reagents and I think you can
see that these topics work to address
some of the issues that you saw in
Friedman Friedman's analysis of
contributors to research reproducibility
now in the publisher side they folks
like nature and science and they brought
together other publishers and they have
also put interventions and play Basking
scientists to deliver more in terms of
materials and methods they're
incorporating the review of additional
scientific statistical experts so
they're also looking at its soundness of
the science and looking to improve now
this quote is from the NIH that
indicating and of course their efforts
these efforts will not be sufficient to
effect real change in our climate that
has demonstrated a problem with research
reproducibility and so I think that
again the the response of the publishers
and the funding agencies government
agencies and professional organizations
have also made suggestions for what we
as scientists should be doing to improve
our success rate with our research but a
question I often think about is well
what about research institutions and
the scientists have conducted research
what about us there's no one really who
cares more about our data and knows more
about or should be driving our response
to how data and research should be
conducted so this question is is being
asked by others this is a nature
commentary which I particularly like
this diagram and in the article they're
asking this question what should
institutions be doing to support their
scientists and to support research
reproducibility and as you see on this
diagram we have on the far left that
funders being held together with
band-aids and the publishers depicted by
nature they are starting to crack the
journals and then what looks like a very
beleaguered scientist is just trying to
figure out how can they do their work in
a strong scientific culture environment
while the robustness and rigor of
science is kind of crumbling around
their head and then we see the
institutions being depicted as being
somewhat asleep in the wheel in trying
to support the scientists in their
effort to meet the needs of the public
the funders in the journals and of
course meet their own needs for
conducting strong research and in this
article they call for what is depicted
there and GIP which are good
institutional practices so they make
recommendations for what might be some
institutional practices that could be
incorporated as strategies for
generating more robust research so again
I'm going to take you back to this table
and propose that when we think about
sound scientific principles these topics
of study design attention to by a
statistical subject matter expert
expansion are being rigorously looked at
by the scientific community and by our
stakeholders however I would also
propose that the second category of good
quality practices that is so much needed
is not being addressed or considered as
strongly as it perhaps should be and
since both are critical for reproducible
research I think that it would be
important for us to think about this so
if if quality for good quality practices
do generate a critical gap in our work
what kind of practices are am I talking
about
so when I speak about good quality
practices I'm talking about at the point
of data and metadata collection are we
able to generate very reliable
transparent results throughout the
lifecycle of our data from the from
source data to archiving and sharing of
data do we have records related to our
equipment the personnel who have
conducted to supported the conduct of
the science our supplies our methods
facility type records or research
records what's the quality of these
records and I'm in call your attention
back to the reproducibility 2020 paper
because the next slide refers to this
area of that our data and metadata
reconstruction are truly critical to
research reproducibility and what do we
know about our ability to reconstruct
our data and metadata as scientists now
this is the graph and I'm hoping you can
see this on your screen well that comes
from the 2020 paper and what it shows is
kind of the life cycle of our research
and as you look closely at it it
indicates quality checkpoints throughout
that process some that are that in
orange that are present some that are
rarely used depicted in grey and as you
can see at the beginning we're we're
we're we're coming up with a project
idea we have and then we go to funding
we certainly have a review process there
because we're working
hard on rating our grants grants are
reviewed by subject matter experts and
when we go through to experimental
design and protocols we have some
general requirements some institutional
requirements that drive how we design
our work but when we actually move into
the the generation of the data where
protocols and reagents and equipment is
used there's very little evidence of
quality control points and as you think
about that you realize that this is the
area where the data and metadata are are
all collected and it seems to me we have
a true gap or a potential gap in quality
control there because we don't currently
have mechanisms beyond mentoring which
of course is a very strong proponent of
research practice but it varies from
mentor to mentor and we plot and we
certainly won't it doesn't generate the
kind of records we need to reconstruct
their data so what do we know a member I
said that I would like to tell you about
what data do we have that illustrates
how we're doing with our ability to
reconstruct data and metadata and these
are the the kinds of studies I'm going
to share with you in the next three or
four slides this is a study of NIH
funded early career scientists in the
United States who say they have engaged
in the particular behaviors you see on
your screen it's a very robust response
over 3,000 scientists answered this
survey and these were anonymously
reported results and remember that since
these are NIH funded scientists they
typically would be considered to have
very strong mentors and strong programs
and as you see these behaviors you'll
see that 12 to 15% are concerned about
their study design methodology perhaps
being influenced by pressure from a
funding group so this would be a some of
the issues associated
with incentive groups and and pressure
groups inappropriate or inadequate
design 14% again I hope being addressed
by some of the approaches being
implemented by our our publishers and
funding and training programs the idea
of dropping observations or data points
based on a gut feeling that they're
inaccurate again this is an important
practice which many of us I think would
would recall reasons for doing this and
and I think that the important thing
here is documentation again about why we
might want to drop data point but it
shows it scientists feel a little bit
vulnerable about those procedures but
the one that I find really interesting
is that about 30 percent of scientists
mentioned that they feel that their
record-keeping is not on what they'd
like it to be and that they recognize
that inadequate record-keeping may be a
problem in their general research that's
a large number of scientists here's
another study and the reproducibility of
science looking at the unique
identification of research resources in
the literature so if this group of
scientists recognize that the inability
to uniquely identify critical research
resources is very important in terms of
research reproducibility and so they
designed an experiment to look at the
identifiability of research resources in
the biomedical literature so again they
went back to the published literature
they created a rubric for and
determining whether research resources
could be identified so then another
scientist could use them in their
research and reproduce the work
interestingly 54% of those multiple
studies across the biomedical platform
of research they looked at many
different types of biomedical
and they found that 54% of those
critical resources were not uniquely
identified in the publications and this
is you know certainly influences the NIH
is interest in having us do better and
uniquely identifying our critical
resources such as antibody lines cell
lines knockout mice reagents another
study that where you see on your screen
whose sample is it anyway this visit
looks at a widespread what they call
miss annotation of samples in
transcriptomics studies where they
looked at based on the data in the
papers what's there a match between the
genomics data and the sex data that
would be expected based on that on that
data and they identify and apparently
mislabeled samples based on the sex and
the correlation that should be with the
data in 46 percent of the datasets
studied can either are fairly surprising
numbers because they have to do with
record-keeping
another study looking at gene name
errors being widespread in the
literature this is recognizing that
there are problems with Excel and how
Excel has default settings that may
create problems in sorting data and what
they found were in the published
literature approximately one-fifth of
papers that contain supplementary Excel
gene lists contain erroneous gene name
conversion and I find these papers very
interesting because these are fixable
problems that may be addressed by
improving practices so basically to me
this looks like some problematic
record-keeping and I think that
record-keeping is a strategy that we
could improve on with with relatively
low pain and I want to make the point
that even regulate
even research that have conducted under
a quality standard has problems with
record-keeping the most common
deficiencies that are reported in annual
summaries of studies that have come
before the FDA for for audit some of
those most common deficiencies include
inadequate record-keeping incomplete
study records inadequate or the lack of
standard operating procedures so this is
a systematic problem perhaps in our
science and it appears to me that some
of the long recommended research Quality
Assurance best practices might help in
this regard and could be a scientist
driven strategy for addressing research
reproducibility and I say that because
quality assurance management systems are
designed specifically designed to
improve and maintain the precision and
accuracy of a product and establish
routine performance in our world the
products that scientists produce are
research data the inference that we take
from those data and of course
publications and we can't forget that
our other product is the next generation
of scientists the critical importance of
our mentoring and the skills and the
best practices we teach throughout our
training programs now in in spite of the
critical importance of data in our lives
in the basic research world whether that
happens on an academic setting or
whether that happens in a research
organization a private research
organization it's generally very true
that quality assurance support and
expertise is rarely found in the basic
research settings and I've found that to
be true beyond academia where basic
research is conducted it's very rare
that Quality Assurance best practices
are there to support the scientific
effort where you do find quality
assurance
is along the developmental pipeline
where we have basic research on the far
left moving through the preclinical
development clinical trials and the
manufacturing environments and where you
see the quality systems come in is where
research is subject to requirements by
law so under good laboratory practices
with clinical practices good
manufacturing practices all of these are
required by the Code of Federal conduct
for research so and a big part of that
is having a quality assurance unit there
to look at and review and safeguard data
however at basic research level where
we're looking at disease discovery and
drug discovery and trying to come up
with some good approaches to impact our
health there's no regulation in place
that very inconsistent approaches to
research and again all of them
mentor-based
and this might be a place where we could
voluntarily integrate some of the
quality assurance best practices to
support the hard work of those mentors
again we've been doing excellent
research for many many many years
but we don't have the data
reconstruction ability to prove that so
what I like about quality management
systems and why I think that they would
be very supportive of basic research and
the scientists that conduct it is that
quality management systems generate
evidence and generate records that allow
us to reconstruct the work either in the
future when we need to reproduce work or
throughout throughout our ability to try
to look at our data and respond to
questions or respond to variability so
when you see this screen you'll see that
quality management system records the
typical type
some records that are collected and
generated have to do with our the
equipment you're using working well is
that well-maintained has it been
repaired do you know that it's measuring
where you needed to measure has it been
calibrated ours do we have records to
show that our methods have been
validated and that appropriate quality
control is being used and you go through
this this slide to see I think you'll
get the idea that that when we look at
these systems and collect good records
we really can stand up for the quality
of our work and it also allows us to do
something we're not so used to in basic
research is the ability to continuously
improve our work so without a quality
system I'd ask the question of whether
we fully support our scientists and the
quality of their data if we do not have
quality systems in place and we just
have a look at these questions now as
you think about the work you do so do
you feel like you would be able to feel
strongly that the research data you are
generating our original accurate
contemporaneous legible secure and
unchanging and can you reconstruct them
is our documentation complete in our
work do we ensure consistency and
procedures and training through the use
of routine standard operating procedures
and do we have training records that
over time we'd be able to look back and
say yes that person was trained to do
that procedure so if we have questions
about the procedure we don't think they
have to do with the person that's
conducting it and then there we ask
about the maintenance of calibration of
equipment especially in our basic
research settings have we given due
thought and do investment to having
strong equipment calibration support
systems and maintenance data and I
believe that strategies really are
needed to fill the gap here in our basic
research settings now I'd like to just
say that research QA is not a new
concept
it has been long recommended since the
early nineties and there are strong
resources and effective resources
available to scientists and I just call
your attention to a few of these the
World Health Organization document you
see on the left and orange quality
practices and basic biomedical research
the rqa research quality Association in
in Great Britain has a very nice freely
available quality system workbook that
is downloadable and can be used and they
also have a very nice little document
called quality and research which is
available for about $10 which gives
guidelines but that can be incorporated
and then there is also a toolkit
provided by the mix and prize and grant
a Association for research QA and all of
these promote the voluntary adoption of
good research practices and basic
research labs and in addition to these
are several publications if you were to
go in Google research Quality Assurance
in basic research you would find
scientists calling for this as well
since the nineties and what's nice about
the Lebel Quality Assurance and about
these resources that truly these best
practices can be adopted by on an
institution level by small teams or by
individual researchers to give you a
little bit more detail about the w-h-o
handbook because it is such a nice
reference or resource that you're
looking for one and you'll see here that
I have some of their content about what
they were trying to do and as you see
they're basically trying to help non
regulatory science scientists who are
not regulated by law to incorporate some
basic QA approaches and to help them
produce credible research data and also
promote the credibility and
acceptability of their work through
their strong record system which we as
scientists have I
define or research on research has
identified as a problem for us and by
doing so we're now in a position to
generate credible evidence which leads
to trust in our data and confidence in
our results so how might how might this
all come together and basically I think
that we should be thinking about data
and research quality at a more micro
approach what might we do to secure and
safeguard the quality of our data and we
can do that by thinking about good
research practices the second tier of
generating sound science so what that
requires is a real focus on data
governance by that I mean what do we do
to secure data from from source data to
people when the data is generated from
the equipment where it's generated by a
particular person when we what are the
analytical tools we use to and analyze
these data IT support in terms of data
governance is it is a big issue we need
to think about our electronic data and
how we're going to handle big data we
really need to support sound science and
good quality practices we need to focus
on training and incentive system and we
need to incorporate some of these
staples or strategies so all of these
issues really will contribute to data
and research quality so to sum up I this
is a commentary that appeared in nature
in January 16 talking about that Quality
Assurance and what they mean by it may
not be sexy and I'm sure that this won't
be a surprise to any of you viewers if
you've experienced quality assurance it
does it does require attention to detail
additional records which need to be
certainly collected by by scientists and
there's
staff and an intention to the full data
lifecycle so while this may not be sexy
or may not be what we call rocket
science it definitely contributes to
rocket science and supports rocket
science and so quality assurance really
is becoming a crucial part of our lab
life and family because as scientists
it's been long neglected in our training
program we may not have the skills and
the best practices as part of our
research environment because they've not
been part of them in the past and so for
that reason I think it's important for
us to think about about integrating
quality assurance best practices in our
research culture in a way to promote
best practices in sound science to
improve data reconstruction and research
rigor but also as a way to support our
scientists so from an institutional
approach I think that we need to be
thinking about institutional centralized
thinking with establishing and
maintaining best quality practices to
support the work we generate and then
it's very important to provide this
critical training to address the gap in
our training that then we aren't
incurred incorporating some chih-wei in
our training program and then lastly
because we've been able to generate
evidence we should be able to much more
strongly demonstrate the quality of our
work to our records and through our
ability to continuously improve our work
by paying attention to those records and
then readily be able to to more quickly
generate our publications because our
records will be in stronger form and and
then also be able to communicate our
quality systems when we're writing
grants or submitting publications to be
able to say that we participate in
in a quality assurance system should
make us stronger candidates for funding
and publication so with that I'll stop
my remarks and and basically plant that
seed that perhaps we could think more
has scientists about how do we drive
research best practices what is our
response to the research reproducibility
issue and how can we be more proactive
to be concerned rather than reacting to
to the best practices that have been are
publishing communities and funder
stakeholders are laying out for us what
what is our response and what can we do
with scientists thank you so much ulis
we want to get right into the questions
and input so here's a reminder as to how
audience members can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q and
a button at the lower left if we're
unable to get to your questions due to
time constraints dr. Davies will reach
out to you via email so let's take a
look at our audience questions dr.
Davies our first audience member would
like to know research QA is a new
approach for basic research laboratories
what suggestions do you have for getting
started with this in a research lab
setting you is that truly you don't have
to wait for an institutional approach I
would very much like to think that
institutions will take this on board and
will provide some support and will
increase their training focus on
research QA but in the meantime there
are steps that you as an individual
scientist could take its say you're a
mentor you're a PI let's say you're an
individual scientist with your you're a
postdoc or you're a graduate student and
you you would like to at least learn
about what these best practices are or
try to integrate some
in your own work all of this is possible
by simply acquainting yourself with what
these best practices are and so my
suggestion would be to go and download
that w-h-o quality best practices and
research and have a look at it it gives
you some real strategies it gives you
forms and templates that you could use
download and use in your own work so
that would that would be my suggestion
is is acquaint yourself with this with
this body of knowledge because if you're
like me as a trained scientist in a ph.d
program you may not have been introduced
to some of these best practices under
the umbrella of quality assurance so the
best place to start is acquaint yourself
with the best practices and then see
where you might be able to integrate
some of them and then secondly to also
talk with this among your peers within
your lab groups and and in those
conversations say is there something we
could do is our laboratory could we
commit to some of these procedures and
then get the benefit of them in ensuring
the credibility of our work thank you so
much dr. danee it looks like we have one
more great question from one of our
audience members if you want to select
just a few of the research Quality
Assurance best practices that are
recommended what would your choices be
and and this is a question that that
I've gotten before from groups that I've
been speaking with about this topic and
and basically I have two answers one
would be to to look at the whole program
and and see what you're already doing
and take advantage of the good practices
you're already doing and just document
them the second thing is to is in order
for this idea to
we really needs to be science centered
and risk-based right so I'm not
advocating that you put in it put in a
comprehensive program that is going to
add too much work to your days so what
you need to do is make this risk-based
approach so if you ask yourself what
what parts of my research caused me some
concern or keep me awake at night am I
worried what am I worried about in terms
of my data what kind of data do I
collect
for instance if it's all electronic data
how do I know that it's not changing as
it gets transferred into spreadsheets or
stored places or generated within
equipment or if you are someone who has
multiple pieces to a research project
multiple people at different sites
collecting data you might be more
concerned about controlling how that
data is collecting are people doing
things consistently how do you know that
people at site 80 or site B are doing
things the way you are expecting it done
in that place an easy place to start and
an important place to start might be to
say to yourself and your project we're
going to have a consistent approach to
some of the routine practices so this is
what standard operating procedures are
made for SOPs are perfect for routine
processes that you want to capture and
make sure consistently conducted so
sample sample collection perhaps if it's
being done in several places you would
want to have an SOP for a center
operating procedure for how those
samples are collected and you would want
to share that with everybody who's doing
it and your training records associated
with that SOP so nailing down your
routine procedures one of the best most
important places to start would also be
having a consensus based approach to how
you manage your data all right so
where are you storing your data what
purchase do you have to Excel
spreadsheets
do you nail down your formula our data
stored in a secure Network can people
edit or change your data unknowingly 2
PI's have access to seeing data in real
time so for me I guess the most
important first step would be sit down
as an individual or group and determine
what your approach to data management is
and make a standing operating procedure
for that but then of course I'm a great
believer in all the other aspects look
at your equipment capture equipment data
make sure you thought about calibration
and maintenances equipment if you're
generating data from equipment and you
can't show records of maintenance and
calibration the truth is your data can
be darn near worthless because you can't
attest to the credibility and quality
control of course is another big piece
do you have quality control in your
methods within your equipment throughout
the research process so that's probably
too long of an answer but there are risk
based places to start thank you for the
question dr. bass baby a stickier and
that was a fabulous answer and did you
want to add to that in with any final
comments in your presentation for the
audience before we close today some new
to the basic research field I can tell
you that it is being incorporated in in
several laboratories we're working with
laboratories of the University of
Minnesota to help them there are
international approaches to helping
scientists with this there are there are
societies the Society for quality
insurance which has university specialty
committees and people who are interested
in how to integrate all
into basic research programs so I really
encourage you as I was interested in
giving this time as a way to plant this
seed and I encourage you to think about
it and to not consider it as they have
bureaucratic overreach by by a
regulatory from a regulatory sense but
think about this as a scientist driven
approach to standing up for the quality
of that very important and precious data
that you generate and the research that
you're conducting for the greater good
thank you thank you so much for this
informative presentation and honestly
thank you for focusing on best practices
of research that is such an important
topic in every field I'd also like to
thank lab roots today for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
until August 2017 keep an eye out for an
email from lavage alerting you when the
webcast will be available for replay we
encourage you to forward this
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us I would hope you come
back next time goodbye